alors on a une petite terrasse tous les
soirs qu'il faut qu'on évacue la philo
c'est la fille de mike tyson vous
expliquer l'histoire redémarre moi de
raconter les connaît c'est bon quoi tu
vois mike tyson
tout le monde a dit qu'on allait payer
pour l'avoir non on n'a pas pu attendre
un peu mais échangent rachat d'or n'a
pas payé c'est un échange marceau on va
montrer sa fille pendant trois jours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je suis le magnéto et sa fille
c'est comme si moi je vous états unis
mon frère j'ai bien aimé chose dit alors
à quand je fais une émission ouverte
mais tu passes mon fils pendant une
semaine tu finis par 4 puis c'est paris
et comme si mike tyson le faire mais pas
se raconter d'histoires c'est vrai mais
bon ce sont six en interview ouais mais
là on n'a pas payé eurosport il demande
25000 euros par appareil
voilà un sport on les aime beaucoup et
mon frère avait déduit résilier le deal
est mieux alors on va pouvoir
alors je vous jure elle était
aujourd'hui les tec lucas pouille c'est
là là là on a fait face avant la vente
du coup l'on se trouve sinon je n'ai pas
vu mais je le sens bien
[Rires]
à mon arrivée
[Musique]
je suis le capot et d'une aura français
et je coach mylène tyson aujourd'hui
et le texte est natif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
photo st just right nicole kidman à
wisches du lac tout ce qu'il ya autour
nixon
[Musique]
et
il a mis paris et tous les mois vous
allez voir ce que vous allez commencer à
la tendance est pas citoyens alors elle
arrive aujourd'hui ou pas